thank you so much for coming on winners
on a wednesday you have built up
a beautiful portfolio of rent to rent
and i've been trying to get you on
winners wednesday now for
a year yeah i think i think so it's been
a while
and you did some training when did you
first come out my training i think 2018
yeah so a couple years ago you and and i
saw that you're doing really well
but why didn't you want to come on
windows wednesday a year ago out of
interest
i just wanted to i think for myself
you know test the waters make sure that
it was all set in stone before i come on
here and sort of say
this is what i do and this is who i am
and i was just to prove to myself that
it does really work yes because rent to
rent
you would think because when we spoke a
year ago about windows wednesday the
money was coming in
but what were you thinking me thinking
how long is this going to happen for
yeah i was like is this is it too good
to be true
am i going to be able to like expand am
i sort of like
stuck now is this can i move forward
with this or where do i go from here so
i think then now that we're slightly
moving into different areas
within a business it sort of proved to
me that actually this can go
a long way yeah now you have built up
a portfolio of rent to hmos yeah
and you've also now gone into service
accommodation as well
how much are you making right now per
month
profit on an average month with your
rent events
so when all units are full and around
about 80
occupancy with the service accommodation
we look at around 4 000 pound profit per
month
and what's the turnover that you're
collecting um so
just under 10 000 pounds great so you're
getting 10 000 then you've got expenses
yeah for about four
and you say that that's on an 80
occupancy with the one service
accommodation
what's the kind of occupancy with the
hmos like how often are they for what
are the voids like
so obviously with like any business you
do you do get voids i suppose
but all of our tenants will give us
plenty of notice so
whenever we do experience a void it's a
week or two weeks and it doesn't really
you know it really doesn't affect the
profit margin there yeah sure so when
someone
puts their notice in then you just
refill it to be honest we have ads
running constantly
spare room gumtree facebook so we're
collecting enquiries and gathering
people's details
for when rooms come available how many
rooms have you got on your hmos right
now
16. 16 and how many of them are full 15
out of 16. okay
so that's pretty good and that that
presumably that one that is empty will
be filled pretty quick
yeah i hope so we did a viewing last
week and the lady is like
going to come back to us so we'll see
yeah
so how did you get into this and tell us
the story of your background and how you
came across
my training and how that all came
together okay great so
um really i was like you know i don't
even know how it came up in front of me
i was just
looking or scrolling on eve i think it
was either facebook or youtube
and i come across yourself and you were
just
holding a camera it wasn't like a camera
crew or anything it was just the camera
and walking around your house
i clicked into it and i was all right
this is interesting it is like seven top
tips for beginners
and uh your wife amanda was on there and
i think she was a i think it was a due
date
for your first child and i was like you
know what this is this is great
was i walking around the field yeah and
then you went out for a walk and
it was so windy and you're just filming
yourself and you're like you should do
this you should do this
and i thought wow like this is this
real you know and in the bottom in the
comments i believe it
gave a link and i ordered your book and
i think i only had to pay for postage on
there
and in the book came two free tickets to
the crash course
so i got booked on to that and come over
to the crash course and then from there
really
what was the crash course like oh it was
amazing
it was amazing and i'd definitely
recommend everyone like i'm going to
bring my mom actually as soon as
you know the whole coronavirus is over
and things resume back to normal
i hoping to bring my mum onto that as
well just i think the motivation you get
when you're in the room and sort of
the atmosphere and the networking
opportunities is just phenomenal now
when you came to the crash course you
must have only been about 19.
yes so i was 19. so what were you doing
at the time were you working were you
studying
yeah so i've always been working pretty
much full time trying to save money and
um in education as well so just already
fingers in my first year at uni um but
had i found this sooner you know i
wouldn't
as much as university does give just
give
value i don't believe i've sort of took
as much away from that in the two years
as i have from coming on your training
and then doing further things with
property
yeah and and what did you study at uni
so i'm doing business management and i
have to return in october for my final
year
and i don't like leaving things um
unfinished so i am going to go back and
finish it off
um is it crazy though that you're going
to be university you're making 4 000
pounds a month
profit 21 years old and you're going to
be at uni
and everybody else that's at una is
going to be thinking i want this degree
so that i can then get a job which is
going to give me money but you're
already there on the money side yeah
it's amazing
it is actually i you know i just i think
like at the start when i finished
college i was like i don't know what i'm
gonna do
um i i had no idea what i wanted to do
really i just thought i'll go and do
business because i do know i enjoy that
and i started the course and everything
and then when i come across this i was
like
what was i thinking i mean i've took a
lot of skills away from it
in terms of you know like body language
and
all things like that which and it has
helped with like confidence and theories
behind things which i have
like come into play in my own business
now i suppose but
i do definitely think that had i have
come across you
potentially a few months earlier then
maybe i wouldn't be going back to uni
in october you know what though you
still came across me pretty young you're
a teenager at the time
yeah a lot of people come across me when
they're in their 40s or 50s
so you you were still sort of young now
one of the things i find really
intriguing
lois is you're based in uneaten which is
not far from where i grew up as well so
you're a midlander like me
and you're making four thousand pound a
month in your property business
but you're continuing a very normal
life you're going back to university you
haven't even quit your job yet
i know what am i what am i doing but i
don't get that
help me out i think sometimes like so
the money's coming in
sometimes we all just make distractions
for ourself i think
so that we don't like not that i don't
want to move forward with things because
i definitely do
but i know to be able to do that i'm
going to need a lot of like time and
dedication
and sort of i use work as a distraction
if you like
because i know i go there i feel as if
i'm using my time wisely
because i'm going to work going home
and then on i'm doing business things
after work when really what i should do
i know what i need to do
is you know get get a little office or
something like that and just focus now
on
moving forward with the business the
seller is there so i can i can take
you know money and i can pay myself
that's not a problem
so i think now i'm in a position where
hopefully
you know then when i go back to uni
definitely i will not be working like
for anybody else so we'll just take a
salary from the company
one of the things you told me as well
previously is that
you feel like if you quit your job it
would force you to have
to grow really going hard at the
property business
yeah whereas at the moment the property
business just sort of ticks over and
it's comfortable and it's nice
yeah and i think that's another thing
like we all just stay in our comfort
zone don't we and we need that extra
push
and i think it's about being around the
right people networking
and you know to get to where you want to
be because it would be so easy for me to
just
carry on exactly how i am but i know and
there's a lot of people around me that
are like
no you need to do this you need to you
know you need to go for it now are you
now in a position where you can start
saving up to stop buying properties
yourself
yeah definitely and i'm hoping that this
year my company will buy a couple of
houses
and then you know turn them into shared
housing just because the cash flow with
that strategies
it's you know it's so good what do your
parents do
my i live with my mum yeah um so she
actually comes in on the business side
of things with me
and she does a lot of cleaning of the
properties okay
yeah um but i do i do want to bring my
mom into the
into the business properly yeah properly
so that your mom's able to
work in the business even if it's a
little bit just a little bit yeah to be
able to be able to get your family
involved in the business is a really at
21.
yeah it's great and i think it will be
great for my mom as well i just need to
bring because me trying to explain it i
think sometimes when someone in your
family tries to explain something to you
it's like in one ear out the other
sometimes not
not like in a rude way that's just how
it goes isn't it a lot of the times
they're like
okay i'll listen to you later or
whatever but
if i bring her along to the crash course
and you know you're there on the stage
and
the atmosphere and everything it's just
unreal she won't
be able to not do something about it
yeah
she or she'll be forced into it so i
think as soon as that's available i'll
bring her on and my grandma as well um
she does property herself
so she has a couple of buy to let's and
she's looking to like move more into the
creative strategies so
potentially we could work there as a
family that is so nice
potential i think what was your mom
doing prior to that i'm trying to get a
bit of a background about yourself
um floristry okay yeah so she enjoys
like
doing flowers and things and what did
you want to do when you were at school
studying which was only a few years ago
what were you asked but did you
want to be financially free in property
like was that part of the plan or did
you want to do it it was never part of
the plan um
honestly i don't i don't even know how
really i'll come across it
i did i have a lot of interest for
property anyway like i've moved 27 times
and i'm only 21 so
you know i've lived in the midlands and
we lived in horsham and crawley and
guildford so we're in the south and
we're coming back and forth a lot
of my childhood and i was always looking
on right moving things and saying to my
mom oh shall we
let's look at this house i love this
house let's have a look at this a lot of
the houses we've lived in i've actually
found
even though i was only a child um
at the time but i just i just when
you know when i seen the video and
everything i thought you know what i
could really see myself going with this
because i just
even the small things like what color
should we paint this
you know decorating the rooms and stuff
like that is part of the service
accommodation business
yeah it's it's something that i really
enjoy doing and although i do want to
become
like a lot more hands-off in the future
it's
you know it's still an aspect of it that
i enjoy i think as well
um long term i was when i was back in
college i was thinking maybe consultancy
so you know going into like businesses
that aren't working so well
and then you know going in trying to fix
them and then leaving and i think
it's quite like similar to property in a
way so you go into a house that's maybe
a bit tired
do it up and then you come away again so
similar aspect talk to me about your
first deal say you're the first landlord
how did you find that landlord how did
you pitch it talk to me about that
honestly the first deal
well it was it was a mess really the
house was
required a lot of work to be done and at
the time we didn't have the negotiation
skills we didn't
you know we were going in sort of
blind if you like we didn't know what to
expect so we did director vender
so as a local hmo landlord however the
when he called and said you know i've
got a house i'd like to show you
it wasn't the hmo we'd inquired about so
it was just a standard um
terraced house it needed a lot of work
doing to it
and we did take it out of our own hands
and we did
um well we actually spent our own money
looking back now
i would never spend that much again on
someone else's property however it's a
massive
learning curve and i think it's brought
a lot of um
you know it's brought us to like where
we are now because
had i not took that you know i think it
gave us like it gave me the confidence
anyway to be able to go on and find more
deals
and then it's like you know when you
meet with agents it's like well i've
done this deal
so when you've got proof
in the world it definitely wasn't
money-wise it
it turns i think um 780 pound profit per
month
and it's only four four rooms so a lot
of my
um hmos are four four rooms
um but they all meet all the
requirements obviously
as they have to anyway but we just find
the four rooms in our area work
so well um and you
you know the tenants are i don't know
how i don't know myself quite how it
would work
and i've looked at a few eight and ten
bedroom houses
and i'm trying to work out how i could
get eight or ten people to get along
yeah interesting i think i think there
are advantages to four
and also usually you don't need a
license for four no you don't
so it is easier that way so this
landlord then this was a property that
was
he wanted to do as a hmo it needed a bit
of work it was tired
you looked round it and you said look
i'll take it off your hands i'll make it
nice
and i'll give you a nice little
guaranteed rent and then i'll run it
myself exactly yeah so we did that we
agreed the rent and when you say where
you talk about you and your mum
no so me and a business partner at this
point yeah yeah so we have that one
property together
yeah um was that someone that you knew
already or someone yeah yeah i mean
i knew already and we took that property
on together because we both
put the investment like the money in to
be able to do how much do you
need to put down for that so we use four
thousand pound each okay
so not crazy crazy money no not crazy
but
i think looking back at it and deals
that i've managed to be able to go into
now you know now i've sort of
the the latest one we secured um
like no deposit and things like that and
i just think your negotiation does get a
lot
better obviously when you that's the
thing when you get good at something
when you've got the knowledge and the
skills
suddenly you can secure much better
deals
but what you did was you took the first
one you said it's not it might not be
the best deal in the world but you just
wanted a deal
to have the experience the learning to
be able to say that you've done a deal
and often you first deal with your
hardest anyway but if you put in total
eight grand and it's making how much
profit a month did you say
um 780 788 so that's making about
nine grand a year so actually that's
more than 100
return on investment yeah so now um
like learning from that we've learned we
want to make
money back within the first six months
yes um
however with that like i said before
because it was our first deal we just
we just really wanted to get something
you know we wanted to get the ball
rolling with it
and anyway a lot of opportunities have
come from that because now i look after
another three properties from the same
landlord
so it has gave more opportunities like
regardless of the work
we did have to put in where did you get
the four thousand pound from
that savings or what was that yeah it's
from savings so i'd been
because originally like you know when
i'm back at school and everything
everyone i suppose they just have their
way of thinking
and mine was i'm gonna go to college i'm
gonna go to uni just
get a job didn't really ever think about
financial freedom like it just wasn't
something that crossed my mind
whatsoever
and um and then i was like and then i'm
gonna save and i'm going to get a
mortgage and i'm going to live in my
house and pay my mortgage off
and it's like now it's complete opposite
i don't
you know a mortgage would be great yeah
but
in set we've set um like requirements
and set
ways it's not necessarily i'm gonna get
my house and pay my house off
yeah because i know there's a lot of a
lot of ways you can make money and
you don't need to put all your money
into one house too exact of course not
you're preaching to the converted sister
yeah yeah so um what was the second what
was the second deal then was that the
same landlord was that different
landlord
um it was a different landlord how did
you find them it's
very easy go on the the guy um so found
it on
was it open rent yup um it's actually a
property above a shop so it's like a
four bedroom
um or could have been five bedroom like
flat if you like but it has gotten
upstairs so it's like a house on top of
a shop
um and he was he was like i went into
the shop and i was like you know i've
come to do the
to view the house and he just gave me
the keys he didn't even want to
come up with me and he'd actually made
it all fully ready
to do exactly what i wanted to do with
it but then he decided something had
come up
and he didn't have time for it anymore
so there it was it just given me the
keys
he said have a look around let me know
what you think we're fully transparent
in
um when we approach landlords we tell
them exactly what our plan is from day
one
just because we don't want to waste our
time don't want to waste my time
and he was like yeah sounds fine to me i
went up had a look i was like wow this
place is nice like
brand new everything had just been
gutted all the way back to brick and
redone so for although we'd spent all
this money on the first deal
the second one you know we had to
furnish it and that was
it that's nice yeah it's really nice so
then we got that
and how much do you pay the landlord
on that it's 720. and how much rent do
you get on that
so just under 2 000 pounds nice and then
you've got a few bills and costs
how much profit you left with that one
um around about 800 850.
that's fantastic so you've got all these
little properties that are giving you
sort of seven eight
hundred pounds a month each yeah and
you're managing it
alongside a full-time job yeah
are you do you pay a management company
or do you do it yourself um so at the
moment i'm doing it myself
it's not the long-term plan but i did
want to you know sort of
get a good understanding of everything
before i pass it to someone else and i
think
like it'll be hard for me to like let it
go to somebody else because i'm just
so i'm very set in my ways and i like to
know things are done
and done properly that's right though do
you know what though it's i think what
you've done
is you've got i guess financial freedom
to a point because
you're making four grand a month profit
every month and you're only
having to keep an eye on it and manage
it part-time so it's certainly financial
independence to
to to a point a lot of people would envy
that
in order for you to get to a point where
it's passive
all you have to do you'd have to do it
if you let's say you got another
five houses and now you're getting eight
thousand pound a month that's not going
to be part time now it's gonna be full
time
but then if you employed someone and
paid them 2 000 a month
then you're paying them 2 000 but you're
getting 8 000
so that's passive does that make sense
yeah i'm definitely
looking at ways now where i can make the
income passive
and so i can work on you know bigger
things i suppose and
let that all run in the background but
another thing is because you've got the
skill
and the and the training and the ability
to be able to find a house
rent it out and get such high rents i
think it's really smart that now you're
you're taking that money that you're
making from rent to rent you're putting
it aside and then going to be buying
with it i think that's really smart and
it's going to open you up now to way
more strategies
yeah i hope so well it is it's just
going to happen and the fact that you're
21
i mean honestly i'm really really
impressed what's it been like
um talk a little bit about your
experience with some of the training
working with me i know we've been
speaking
and stuff what am i like off camera am i
the same or different
the same exactly the same and when you
came to the crash course
was there any part of you that was
thinking this is absolute
bs well i didn't
when i come to the crash course i wasn't
really skeptical at anything because i
had no expectations you know i was just
coming along really to see what it's
about and um
what i liked is everything you were
saying matched up with a book so i
thought you know this guy's
really always got his book he's you know
saying the same thing on stage
and i think he gave out there was like
um a packet
a package on everyone's seat and it had
like
um something in and we read it
and you were making us read it and it
was like declarations
a declaration yeah and i was stood there
and i was thinking am i going to read
this out loud
really am i and you were like it said
something like i am a property investor
and i thought i can't say that like this
is my first day on the course
and um anyway so that was the only thing
and
even when i look back at that now i
think do you know what that i think it
like
it tells it teaches you to tell yourself
that you are
you are already there and then obviously
your actions
follow don't they because you know
the motivation and everything in the
room you had us all up and dancing and
oh it's amazing because the thing is if
you if you if you can speak out i am a
property investor
i can do this and you're in that mindset
you're right your actions will then
follow and you're speaking to
existence if you come to a course and
say this is going to be rubbish
you know i'm not good at this i'm broke
i've got no money i can't do this
then if that's what you're saying over
your life that's exactly what you're
going to manifest so you came as a 19
year old
with no property experience at all and
came and ran with it and you've done
super super well
yeah thank you and i think as well like
when you tell yourself
like you said like um you know you keep
telling yourself
if i can't do if you keep saying i can't
do it i can't do it you you just become
that
you just if you keep saying oh i can do
i can do this and every day
you get up and you're like you know
today i'm going to do a little bit more
than i did yesterday
then it all becomes like a reality
doesn't it yeah
what's been the biggest lesson for you
and what's been the biggest key learning
point over the last
couple of years in actually doing the do
not theoretical but actually doing it
right there's been a lot a lot of
that's okay no there's a lot of like
learning curves i've learned along the
way and i think um
i know i've only been doing it for a
short period of time but even now if i
could go back
there's a lot of things i'd do
differently and just like really small
major
like really small things but which can
become quite major like
doing group viewings people wasted time
taking deposits if people say they're
interested in a room but they want it in
four weeks time
maybe at the start i would have been
like okay that's not a problem just
message me when you're ready to take the
room
but now it's like if you if you want the
room you're gonna have to put a deposit
because i
can't keep wasting other people's time
showing them around in my own time
if you are going to take the room yeah
or you know if you're not
so important so group viewings and then
also with
um electricity and gas
had some nightmares i do say um
when we've like took properties on
because i've never lived on my own i've
lived with
with my mom um i've never really thought
you know you have to
when you get the keys to a house you
need to take the meter reading it's
never something that ever ever crossed
my mind
and then i'd be you know sorting all the
bills out on the house and i'll
ring them up and they'd be like oh can
you tell me the immediate readings for
the day you took the property
and i'd be like oh no like but
obviously now a lot of houses are having
smart meters which is really useful
but i do i do think now when even when i
go and view houses
something on my chat checklist is is
there a water meter in the property
and is there a smart meter in the
property because they're two very like
influential things in the bills i think
and also your time
because if you haven't got a smart meter
and you're having to like either visit
your property or get a tenant to send
you the reads
and i had them one landlord actually and
um
it's like slightly difficult the roof
was leaking and with our contracts
you know with guaranteed rent the roof
isn't something that we look after
because it's just
it's a very expensive cost and the the
roof is leaking which caused
for obviously one of the tenants to not
be happy in paying the rent which then
affects
the business i've still got to pay the
landlord supposedly because it's
guaranteed rent
but the the roof's leaking and is not
fixing it so we've had a few
difficulties like that along the way
which probably could have been avoided
how did you how did you deal with that
in the end um what what so something as
part of the service now
um is what i offer if there's an issue
with any of the external things that i
don't cover
um i'll collect three quotes for the
landlord i'll send the quotes over to
the landlord i'll even arrange for it to
come
if the landlord hasn't got the cash flow
for it i'll just deduct it
if obviously agreed with the landlord
say if he hasn't got 900 pounds to
replace the roof
if the rent was 900 pound or
say 700 one month i just wouldn't pay
him for one month
and then pay him the remaining the next
if you see yeah because it helps them as
well and uh
the last thing i want is my tenants
leaving because there's a leaking roof
yeah
because it does have a knock-on effect
yeah i mean
your property knowledge now is so
so good and it's great great to see i
can't imagine
that you could get that kind of
knowledge in your brain from property by
going and studying property
at a traditional university no not at
all
and it's a lot of on job learning isn't
it you need to do it to
to learn and you need the people around
you with the experience that you can ask
and you can
you know like on facebook like i can
message you or whatever
yeah and you'll reply and you'll be like
no do this or you
do it this way and the same as in like
you know the community groups there's so
many helpful people in there you pop a
post up and
yeah everyone wants to help you and
you'll get inundated with messages
i know it's great what do you think has
been the toughest part what's been
did you ever feel like quitting or did
you ever think oh this is just too much
um i haven't felt like quitting um
but that the roof issue did really was
really stressful
um however i've learned you know going
forward how to deal with things like
that um
i'd probably say one of the most like
difficult things
with it is being young because when you
like approach agents especially
and they're so used to their
regular ast agreements and you know will
move a family and move a family out
it's really difficult and i find it's
even more difficult when you're young
because
sometimes i think does she know what
she's on about or
as well when i'm showing prospect
tenants they're like oh okay so are you
the owner
of the property or are you are you going
to be my landlord and they'll be like a
40 year old man
and they'll be looking at me like well
this is weird
yeah i know you know that's funny i can
so relate to that yeah do you think
that's is that hard is it funny
is it weird how does that mean i think
at the start i found it really like
um i found it really difficult to
to tell like for me to tell them that
yeah like this i am looking after this
property
like because i think because my
confidence wasn't great and i was like
i had to now believe a bit more in
myself i'm like yeah
i am managing this property and yes i am
the landlady if you do need anything
this is it'll be me who needs contact
so now i've completely overcome it but
at the start it was very difficult
especially
like taking your first house on um i
think you just need to believe that you
can do it because
if you don't that's when like even i've
noticed with myself now i'll go on
a stay agent viewings and they will
never ever ask
to see other properties but i always say
i can provide references and i can
also show you around any of my other
properties if you like you'd be more
than welcome to
you know to come and do a visit and they
never asked to and i just think it's
about having the confidence and
isn't it because yeah i could have said
that
if i wanted to before i had a house well
you could have done it you could have
you know but then but then you're so
right it's all about just about
confidence and that's why when i do my
financial freedom challenges
and i start from scratch with nothing
i'm able to get deals
yeah it's just because you've got the
confidence in you yeah
yeah and i bet when you watch the ff
challenges you might be impressed but i
bet you think i could probably do that
no i don't i'd love to think i could but
you kind of have done that
yeah not as quick not as quick but i do
think as well like
you should never really compare yourself
with other people's journeys because i
do
i find myself doing that a lot and i
know i have a lot on with uni and with
working full-time
and i shouldn't really sit there and
think oh i could have i could be here
now i could be there
because i'm not and i'm here you know
and i'm going at this pace and that's
okay
because as long as you do more than you
did yesterday and that's fine absolutely
and i think
your only competition really is yourself
it is yeah
and everyone has different like stories
and backgrounds and
family lives and everything there's so
many impacts isn't that into a way
absolutely i think the only time you
should be looking at other people
is if you're looking for people to
aspire to be like
for inspiration rather than to feel
rubbish about yourself
talk to me about confidence because
that's i know it's been a bit of a big
thing for you
yeah um i think just
you know like being around the right
people the support networks and things
and coming on the courses and like just
networking events in general has helped
improve
a lot but definitely this time last year
i wouldn't have
like like you said you asked me to come
here a year ago if i didn't
i should have but i just think i wasn't
ready myself it's just about believing
in yourself
but you're not the only one there's so
many people that do the training
become financially independent or go
make some you know good amount of money
but they're too afraid to come and share
it or they think oh i don't know
because or maybe they're comparing
themselves to other people that have
been on winners wednesday and they don't
they don't feel that they're
quite as good or they're quite as but um
but the thing is i almost feel like
sometimes
being unconfident is almost robbing
other people
because you're not giving like even with
that example you're not giving instead
of saying you know what this isn't about
me i want to come on the show to
inspire other people or when you're
speaking to a landlord oh i'm going to
be unconfident i'm not going to make an
offer actually i want to help him
and i've got a valuable service i've got
a valuable product and i'm going to
put forward my offer with confidence
actually you're helping people
yeah and i think that's like part of it
like i've come to realize now that
i'm offering a solution to people's
problems p there's a lot of landlords
now that will contact me and say
like the most recent one for example
when i explained it to him
he was so happy that he could receive a
guaranteed rental amount
not have to worry about his house not
have to worry about like
you know the tenant so i can send him
regular like videos of the house or he
can pop around whenever he likes and
for him it was just you know i think
yeah it solved one of his problems
because he's busy and he's working
full-time and
he's doing what he enjoys to do and that
wasn't what he enjoyed doing he didn't
want to be
keep changing the tenants or yeah you
know
what would you say to a landlord in fact
what are the
toughest questions that you get from
landlords so when you're offering this
service what kind of things do they say
or objections do they come up with
so a lot of them will want to know how
i'm making my cut
in the money so obviously i'll just
explain that we will make the necessary
like amen
amendments to the house to be able to
either use it as service accommodation
or
to rent it out on a room by room basis
um
another objection will be like because
i'm young again they'll be like oh well
can i trust you with my property
um what happens if all of those people
all of your tenants don't pay you rent
them then what happens to me um so
you'll get a lot of things like that and
also i think they think
like what's she going to do with my
house like i i can do what
she she wants to do um
i've had actually i've been in viewed
houses before and a couple months later
i've seen them on airbnb booking.com
after i've been there and said what i
would do with the property yeah um
how does that make you feel you know i
don't mind because there's plenty of
houses and plenty of money to be made
for absolutely everyone isn't there um
so there's
it doesn't it doesn't bother me at all
that's the absolute right attitude i
mean
human nature is hey you put your house
on on for rent for
600 i came and offered you 600. you then
started being nosy and asking me what
i'm going to do and i graciously
explained and then you robbed the idea
and did it yourself
that is human nature but actually it's
got to be complete win-win
the last thing you want is a resentful
landlord that's like
you're paying me this much but you're
renting it for how much and then they
get resentful so
like you i think it's best to just say
look this is what i'm going to be doing
in fact why don't you do it
yeah i think if it if it works it's
gonna be you've got to be in a position
i suppose the landlord needs to
also need your help if he doesn't need
your help then it's not a win when is it
the people that do it will probably lose
because they've not had the training
yeah you're right or you'll see it and
you'll when you check on airbnb or
whatever
it's on there because they haven't got
any bookings but
you know they haven't got the same
contacts or they haven't built that up
yet yeah but
i think it's just it's just one of those
things isn't it and
it does happen what do you think because
when i said to you about some of the
skills that you've learned on the job
you some of the stuff you talked about
was technical skills
like the meter readings and things like
that very very technical and then other
things was more
people skills like dealing with tenants
and convincing landlords
what do you think the split is between
you as a person and your abilities about
to communicate and
sell and persuade people and smooth
things over when there's problems and
deal with tenants
and then what what percentage of it is
like technical
um type property type stuff what would
the split bay
i think it's a very much a people's
business i mean although it's obviously
about the
houses and things you've got the
communication
skills and all that have got to be there
so i'd probably say
maybe 70 people 30 percent
like property i think that'll be fair
and it's just interesting different
people's perspective because
sometimes people think that if you have
all the technical skills
you're going to really win but i think
that the people skills
it's just as important yeah i'd say
maybe yeah maybe 50 50 then because it
is they are both as important as each
other
and you need to use the right contracts
and you need to know all the technical
technicalities and the break clauses and
deposits and how to register them and
all that 100 but you also need the skill
to be able to talk to people and sell
yeah i think even if you had
all the property knowledge and all of
that behind you
and one percent people skills it's it
wouldn't work so it's got to be
do you think you can learn the people
skills you can yeah you can develop them
over
over the time and i think that's
something that i have
benefited from uni like group work and
things like that that's something that i
have
bennett benefited from for the company
yeah because i think because sometimes
people say to me
and i don't know what the answer is but
they say you're just born
successful you're just born to either do
it or not do it i disagree
yeah i don't think that's true no i
think you can learn it because when i
started in property i was 17 i had
very little going for me and everything
that i've built up i've had to graft and
learn to get the skills you don't you
don't naturally
sell well to people and negotiate a deal
and that doesn't matter it comes with
time doesn't it and experiences
experience and you've got to do it and
you've got to learn it
so i think as a trainer i can train
anyone who's willing and this is really
important oh i believe
um anyone can be financially free but
not everybody will
because it's it takes a lot of
commitment it takes a lot of dedication
and most people aren't prepared to do it
but if you're prepared to
to learn and implement i mean who am i
to say oh that person won't ever be able
to do it that person's
it's a mindset isn't it it's definitely
a mindset thing if you go in there
you know open arms knowing and like
listening and being able to adapt
yourself and take on the
new ways then you can do it but if you
like sort of
closed arms it's going to be a lot more
difficult talk to me about the house
that you managed to secure
which frequently was the house that you
lived in as a kid
so i'd noticed um obviously i'm always
checking right move
zoopla um some right move and i
filtered it as you're showing this on
the to do on the crash course
oldest first thing we did yeah so sat
there one night having a look through
sending my inquiries over
and i come across a house and not only
was it
actually where i used to live as a child
but it was up with two agents so it
stood out anyway
and i said to mum i showed it to my mum
i was like this is where we used to live
isn't it
she's like oh yeah but she couldn't
remember the landlord's
surname so anyway i decided
be best to i approached the agent
the agent said the landlord definitely
would not be interested
and i thought um okay well that's
it's a strange because we know we knew
the landlord and he seemed you know
like he had i know he had a lot of
properties and things and he also was a
very busy guy
and um i brought the property deeds and
dropped him a message on facebook for
you know just
not not too professional just i really
knew him my mom knew him anyway
dropped him a message and he's like yeah
come around for a cup of tea so went
round to his house
um he grilled me for a long for a long
time it was quite difficult and he sort
of
you know he had i think he got he's one
of those landlords that goes exactly by
the book
and because he'd never heard of this
sort of thing before he was
he was open to it but he had a lot of
questions that needed to be answered
for us to move forward with anything
anyway after the meeting i went and
viewed the house
and then eventually negotiated a four
week free rent period to get it all
painted and furnished
um we didn't have to pay a deposit on
that either
and the rent was already a very very
well
it was already very well priced for the
area and then we got the keys i think
that was in september or
october so that was about nine ten ten
months ago
around about ten minutes ago yeah yeah
and you pay him how much
550. and how much do you rent it out for
so that service accommodation
oh 140 pound a night wow
and are you getting bookings well yeah
we're full on a 21 night booking at the
moment
some guys from belgium have booked and
they're working
locally on like a solar dance
it's really crazy and the sort of people
that like you connect with
having these things on offer as well
like you meet a lot of professional
people and
you know before it never really crossed
my mind that like people would be coming
like we had people from like milan and
australia and come and stay in this
house to work on a job a couple minutes
up the road and
you know you're driving in your local
town you don't think about
it it just never crosses your mind does
it do you love
this business i do i love it there's
nothing i love more
i think if i just wake up and first
thing i love houses
and i do i'm hoping you know in the
future i'd love to have my own
construction
company build our own flats and houses
and
all sorts what does it feel like when
you get 21-day bookings
paying how much a night so that was 140.
140 pound
140 140 100 421 times
and you've only got to pay the landlord
550 quid like how how
how does that make you feel it's amazing
honestly it is
and those bookings are the best ones
because obviously there's
like less um running
costs if you like because we haven't
gotta keep going like no one's gonna go
in and change the bed in and we offer
them a clean if they wanna
mid-stay clean but it's just it is
amazing
what would you say to someone that was
watching this and was just thinking
i wanna do that i wanna learn about
property i want to get
houses and what would your advice be get
your book
get samurai's book first i'd definitely
recommend ordering his book
as soon as you've um ordered it book on
the crash course but make sure you read
the book first because a lot of it will
come to sense once i've read the book
and then i listen to you on spotify um
youtube oh you know i'm on my way to
work i'll have you on there
with somebody like i'm sitting here
today telling their story because i just
think
it's it's so important like i've
probably said it so many times already
but
it's so so important to like be
surrounded by people doing the same
thing or even
at least hearing it because if you just
sit back it would be so easy for me now
to just
carry on with my normal life and not
move forward in any aspect of like the
business
but i don't want to fall into that like
comfortable position
yeah and now you're part of the winners
wednesday community
i know that's so exciting and i can't
what does that mean so
we do regular like meet-ups and dinners
and
also we'll get to like is there a
facebook community is it now i think
yeah yeah so i'm excited to get on that
absolutely great
massive asset because i like to spend my
time with people like you
who are actually implementing and as a
trainer
there's nothing more satisfying and we
have so many success students and every
week we've got a new
only person on this wednesday but for me
it just gives me so much joy so
thank you for coming on the training
thank you for implementing thank you for
just being an absolute rock star
and for coming on monday wednesday well
thanks so much for having me and
i can't wait to see you in the group